- We're here with the HGTV stars
Mike Jackson and Egypt Sherrod.
And we're also here with Simone,
one of our viewers who
wanted Mike and Egypt's help
creating a mudroom on a budget,
which we did over there and
it is absolutely stunning.
And now, Egypt,
you're gonna show us a brilliant DIY hack
to organize shoes for less $100.
What is it?
- So we have created shoe
storage cubbies out of PVC pipes.
Literally six inch PVC pipes,
wrapped them creatively with wallpaper,
again, stick on wallpaper,
to give you this look.
What's fantastic about it is
whether you're in an apartment
or you're in a big house,
no one can ever have enough storage.
So you can make this as large as you want,
just add more, as small
as you want, as high,
you can even do abstract designs with it
because look at this.
They don't move!
- How do you do this, Mike?
You pre-buy cut PVC?
How do I approach this?
- [Mike] You wanna partake this?
- Yes. Okay, all right.
- Come on out.
- Thank you, Simone, get in there.
- You're getting anxious.
So you take that, that's
gonna be yours, right.
This is gonna be mine.
PVC usually comes precut,
right, usually at 24 inches.
So at your big box so you
can have them cut it for you
to the size that you need.
Now we have some sandpaper here
because when they cut
it the edges are jagged.
So you wanna sand that down
so it's nice and smooth.
Okay.
So PVC, your wallpaper,
it's peel and stick.
So grab your corner, put that down,
peel this off, let's get a edge.
- Let's see if she can
do it with her nails.
I believe in you, you got this.
- [Simone] Oh this is this,
wait just a second, time out.
- Oh she gon (indistinct).
Oh, I got mine too.
- Usually I'm the one
that does the wallpaper,
but the funny thing was
let you do this today.
- [Drew] Oh yeah, good one, Simone.
- See, what happens
when you move too fast,
we weren't supposed to take
the paper all the way off.
- I'm competitive.
- But go ahead, see, that's
what you get for being too fast.
- So anyway, put your piece
down, take your PVC piece down.
Now mind, you can put any
type of wallpaper on there,
make sure it's peel and stick,
for your design aspect.
You ready?
See?
- Thank you, ladies.
- Let's grab a edge.
- At home it's a lot easier.
You don't need four people.
(audience laughing)
- [Simone] Really?
- The key is-
- I did these three though.
- They look great.
- You start it first and you
peel back the underlayment
and roll back.
See how you're rolling now?
- Oh yes.
And then it makes it, look at that.
Look at that, beautiful, you got it.
- Okay, so if you look-
(audience applauding)
Drew, Simone, we left this gap on purpose
because we don't want the
glue or double-sided tape
sticking to the wallpaper
because it can rip the wallpaper off
and then they won't be able to
stick to each other properly.
Cool beans?
- Cool beans.
So the tape would go here
and then you would just
stick 'em together.
These are already stuck together.
And then we would build on
top of each other as such.
- So Simone, we wanna send you
home with a $1,000 gift card
so you can get everything how
you see fit to your style.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much, Egypt.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much.
- Thank you Simone, so much,
and thank you Mike and Egypt.
(audience applauding)
All right, and you stream
"Married to Real Estate"
on Discovery+ and watch them
compete on "Rock the Block",
one of my favorite shows ever on HGTV.
(upbeat music)